signs you're dating an immature boy and not a good man
I feel like we should all know this,
but here's some signs that you're dating a boy and not a man
Ladies if you're single right now,
listen up! because we all know that age does not equate to maturity
guys can still be in their 30s,
40s, or even 50s and still act like immature boys
and come on you probably know a couple.
we're not getting any younger,
so we don't have time to waste on immature boys right?
here's how you can differentiate the men from the boys
How you can tell he's an immature boy,
number one if he goes partying
and post pictures of himself partying all the time
maybe he's going to a concert, rave,
Coachella, burning man,
steer clear and run far!
unless of course you're also interested in that
If he’s posting pictures with bottles and girls and other Chad looking guys,
run! he's a boy,
not a man!
number two- if they ask for your Snapchat before asking for your number
Should come as a no brainer,
because oftentimes if you add someone's number,
then you can find them on Snapchat.
why not just be a man and ask for the number?
okay that is a boy,
not a man
No. 3 if he has to pregame before any social event
Men who are mature do not need a pregame
they can wait until said event and buy their alcohol there
okay we're not 18 anymore
we can afford the booze
That is a boy, not a man
No. 4 if they don't ask you on a date
okay if a man is really interested in you
he's gonna ask you on a date
not continuously text you
just to leave you on that
is a boy not a man
No. 5 if he never pays for you
meaning if he's taking you out on dates and you're always splitting the tab
then he's showing you that he's not able to provide for you as a man
That’s a boy not a man
ladies please pay attention to the signs
and realize if you're dating an immature boy or a man!